[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres herzhaftes
rezept ich habe eine quiche gemacht mit
brokkoli und getrockneten tomaten das
ganze vegetarisch murat weiß noch nichts
davon aber er darf gleich im anschluss
probieren und ich denke er wird
begeistert sein die tat ist nämlich
super schnell gemacht sie ist wirklich
sehr würzig sehr lecker man kann sie
waren oder auch kalt essen und man hat
echt nur 15 bis 20 minuten
zubereitungszeit plus natürlich die
backzeit ich zeige euch mal die zutaten
die ich dafür benötige für den quark öl
teig brauche ich 175 gramm mehl 100
gramm magerquark 1 1
ich habe ich einen halben teelöffel salz
einen halben teelöffel backpulver sind
viertel teelöffel chili um 20 milliliter
olivenöl und für die füllung brauche ich
150 gramm brokkoli röschen 100
milliliter sahne 100 milliliter milch 1
150 gramm getrocknete tomaten dieselöl
gelegt 50 gramm pro jahr käse und 100
gramm pop und salz und pfeffer ich habe
jetzt hier schon mal ein bisschen wasser
aufgesetzt und da auch salz und etwas
nach vorn rein gegeben und deswegen
damit der frohe kunde auch schön grün
bleibt und sobald das wasser kocht werde
ich den vogel der in etwa zwei bis drei
minuten blanchieren also einfach ein
bisschen kochen lassen und dann abgießen
wasser kocht gleich aber ich habe so
lange die zeit und kann ich hier bereits
den teig zusammenmischen und der quark
öl teig ist einfach wirklich super
leicht und nicht so schwer wie ein
mürbeteig jetzt gebe ich einfach alle
zutaten hier rein erstmal die trockenen
verbinden
also habe ich jetzt mehl backpulver und
die gewürze und jetzt gebe ich hier noch
den quark dazu dann auch das 1
und das ist jetzt verbinde ich die
zutaten kurz und kann sie dann mit der
hand noch ein bisschen kneten aber
wirklich nur so lange bis der teig schon
verbunden ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den teig skripte weiter und kann mich
jetzt um die füllung kümmern und dafür
nehme ich jetzt den porree und schneidet
ihnen einfach in feine streifen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich auch die tomaten klein
schneiden
[Musik]
und zum schluss noch in grün käse fein
reiben
und der passt da wirklich wunderbar rein
denn er ist wirklich sehr witzig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das habe ich alles vorbereitet und kann
alles in der form geben ich nehme es
hier eine tat vor mit hebe boden so
bekomme ich die key später ganz einfach
wieder raus werden im durchmesser von 20
zentimetern und diebe sprüche es mit
etwas back trance gray und dann kommt
sie auf meine dauer back folie und die
habe ich auf dem backblech schon drauf
jetzt kann ich den teig ausrollen und
möchte auch dass hier ein rand ist das
heißt ich muss den teig ein bisschen
größer ausfallen etwa auch 26 cm
durchmesser in der total lustig den
silly flocken richtig schön bunt
jetzt kann ich den teig in die form
reinlegen und einfach so ein bisschen
aus formen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mir ist nämlich einfach die schlüssel
die ich gerade eben hatte zum teig
verrühren und da gebe ich es die zwei
flüssigkeiten also milch und sahne rhein
war sogar richtig waren nämlich bisschen
dickflüssige dann das ei und den käse
und da kann ich die zutaten kurz
berühren
hier ist ein bisschen pfeffer rein und
beim salz müsste einfach kurz
abschmecken
denn der käse ist er wird sich die
getrockneten tomaten sind würzig und den
brokkoli habe ich auch in salzwasser
gegart
jetzt gebe ich hier den lauf schon mit
rein und auch die getrockneten tomaten
und verrührt das ganze noch mal kurz
jetzt kann ich das ganze hier bereits
auf den teig drauf geben und schön
verteilen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt ist er noch schön die populärsten
drauf was habe ich noch viel talg samira
polymer akku ließ und wenn man fragte
mich dann sagt sie immer einfach
abkochen mit bar
und jetzt kann die kita und im backofen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die tat gebacken und ich habe
ein bisschen abkühlen lassen so lässt
sie sich ein bisschen besser schneiden
und auch herauslösen ohne verbrennen und
wegen dem hebel boden als jetzt
vorhergesagt so ein bisschen den rand
gelöst kann ich das jetzt gut rausheben
mal glück rutscht von ganz alleine
lieber muss ehrlich sagen auch die
zuschauer wissen ist auch schon ich
werde kein kind stellen muss ehrlich
sagen ich will auch kein gemüse feld ich
weiß also was heißt gemäßigt marktgemüse
aber jetzt nicht so nicht kommen du hast
du dich ruhig bleiben
ja das dunkle ehrlich profitieren könnte
ich bin glücklich ich mache es nicht
also ich liebte sparen geht so schnell
und ist es einfach lecker richtig lecker
ich habe aber den beiden lieben brüder
kehrte mit rein
das heißt gewählt
ein schweizer käse das ist ordentlich
weg sagt über mich nein du schmidt gar
nicht schlecht ja ja dann die
getrockneten tomaten sind auch gut oder
gar kein fleisch der jedes mal als ich
mit einem ganz schlecht aber man könnte
noch fleisch zu machen man könnte wenn
man möchte aber durch geradezu dog
getröstet und daher brauchte kein
fleisch wenn du schinken oder speck
bereit macht ja das wird echt gut passen
aber ich hab gedacht ich halt mal
menschlich passt so bereiten wir jetzt
mal wird auch gut passen
ich meine es dir und vor allem wir
nichts halt schön dass der pole wirklich
schön grün bleibt es kommt durch das
nach dem wasser wenn man das nicht macht
wird er halt echt braun und unansehnlich
und ich finde es auge ist einfach immer
mit und ich mag es immer gerne wenn
gemüse auch noch eine schöne farbe hat
und auch noch günstig der populist auch
nicht zu weich wie das perfekte obwohl
ich jetzt nicht gewinnen
als ich mich stellt das nämlich nicht
gut das ist doch mal ein großes lob für
mich eher an mit dem rad mag
normalerweise keine quiche weil sie das
rezept auch gerne nachmachen möchte
findet ihr es auch sallys - club.de ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
und wir sehen uns im nächsten mal will
ich mich gut ich weiß und meersalz aber
ich hab's vergessen dass sein haken gut
schmeckt brauchen wir anscheinend nicht
viel salz der krise wollte
ich hab mich weg nicht vergessen weil
die salzmenge lämmer
[Musik]
[Applaus]